welcome back our studio is filled with
birthday boys and girls today because
it's 2 22 22.
it's my birthday too and i cannot
contain
my excitement because we have teamed up
with one of my favorite stores on planet
earth to organize a very special
surprise for you
another giveaway so here is the deal
you're all to go home with a 100
gift certificate to the container
you know what
i actually think that the container
store
is on par with wellness when you are
organized you are clearer in your mind
and in your mood so i have mad respect
totally clean space painters please
please clean mine right your head is as
messy as your room is exactly like when
i heard it it haunted me for the rest of
my life
and it's true
so rossi here you're going to show us
yes some happy hacks um to attack your
kitchen chaos absolutely because today
is 2 22 22 the the last most organized
day of the century if you think about it
the container store is offering 22 off
everything today only for everybody
and i found a few fun ways to use their
product now i want to talk to you about
one of my shame areas it's under the
kitchen sink anybody else where it's
like all the cleaning supplies are a
mess well
i found a way to organize it instead
grab one of these large lazy susans
right here see it turns like this and
then you can put all your cleaning
supplies in it put this under the sink
and then just spin it easily to grab the
cleaning supply you need how much better
is that than the nightmare we have under
our sink right now
well let's move on to our kitchen
counters you all have like all the oils
and the spices and everything it can
become a real disaster zone well i'm
obsessed with these stackable bamboo
storage bins they're perfect for the
kitchen and a great way to store your
oils and your spices and to keep
everything contained and neat and i like
to decant my olive oil or my vinegars
into these beautiful little bottles to
keep them fresher and i want to show you
we have one of these bottles we have a
little funnel from uh container store no
please use your funnel ma'am hello
you're dressed up hello hold on don't
don't break she's on a roll i i i'm like
i can't break my stride now rossi she's
in her party dress and she's risking it
all by not using a funnel let's see can
she do it
oh my gosh she did it
so if you just seal this now it actually
helps your oils and vinegars last even
longer because it's airtight and look at
this on your countertop rather than that
mess oops that we usually have i agree
because when i see this i think wood out
display display
all right i want to next
move you over here
well can we talk about one of
the the most shameful places in
anybody's house a junk drawer do you all
have one
well here's an example of a normal junk
drawer look this gives me anxiety
disgusting right well i want to show you
what this junk drawer can look like
and this drawer is the exact same number
of things look
boom oh my gosh now that that is exactly
what is in the drawer down here and this
is what like a utensil organizer you
usually use forks or knifes in here but
they can be used for organizing as well
[Applause]
this one is bamboo and it can fit all
different spaces and it look how
beautiful it looks that is art exactly
powerful and if you're junk drawers
together girl your life is together
congratulations to you that's true well
speaking of drawers the container store
wants to welcome everyone to the
organization with a fun challenge they
want you to share your drunk drawer on
tick tock and use the hashtag
show us your drawers and tag the at
container store
and i'm going to be showing mine on the
drew barrymore shows tik tok and it's
not as cute as that one trust me
so you know what let's do this together
i'm in 2 22 22.
show us your drawers at the container
store we'll be right back
[Music]
you